welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and out of all the
creepy spooky things that crawled out of
the multiverse of madness by far one of
the most haunting items was undead dr
strange's soul-infested cloak not only
is it definitely the most metal
superhero accessory of all time it's a
brand new variation of strange's cloak
of levitation even for the comics but
although this is technically the soul
cloak's origin story there are plenty of
clues sprinkled throughout the comics
that hidden to answers to some of my
questions about it today i'm going to
explain what i think the soul cloak is
and theorize about how and why it works
before communing with the dark hole to
dreamwalk into his variant's corpse
strange warns christine that the souls
of the damned will come for him and that
she'll need to protect his body while
he's under in parallel to the scene from
the first dr strange movie instead of
shoving a giant needle through the chest
of his unconscious body to keep him
alive christine's now the only defense
between his conscious mind and his
unconscious physical form but why do
these demonic spirits come for him where
are they coming from how exactly does
strange control them some possible
answers to these questions could be
found within the pages of the darkhold
and its extended tones in the comics the
text of the darkhold was written by the
elder god chathan on indestructible
flesh parchment in a chamber within
mount wondercore these spells would
later be transcribed into several
scrolls and the shiatra book of the
damned or the book of sins these works
serve as a source for the necronomicon
and other dark works as we learned in
wandavision and the multiverse of
madness the user of the darkhold is
cursed as the book's evil consumes them
further with each reading in the comics
a long list of magic wielders and
superhumans have lost themselves to the
darkhold their souls forfeited to
chathan we also see in multiverse of
madness that the darkhold has powers
that transcend its own reality not only
is it the blueprint for dreamwalking
across the multiverse but it gives wanda
the ability to command demons from
realms beyond her own and ultimately
proves to be linked to other versions of
the darkhold throughout the multiverse
this is key because it indicates that
the power of the mcu's chathan extends
beyond individual realities and likely
operates from a realm in between realms
it would make perfect sense that doctor
strange triggered this outburst of
phantasms from outside the scope of the
contained 616 reality this explains how
the spirits were able to move from
zombie strange's body in universe 616 to
sinister strange's sanctum and how they
knew what dreamwalking was to me all of
this points to the splinter realms a
collection of dark realities that once
were known as the dark dimension long
ago the dark dimension was fractured
into several different planes of reality
including the nightmare dimension the
realm of madness mephisto's realm and a
bunch of other connected worlds in the
comics that would need a whole other
video to explain our friends at epic
hero shop just dropped their epic summer
collection these t-shirts and tanks are
inspired by various alcohol brands with
a twist of nerd they've got asgard ipa
merch from fat thor brewing company bat
cardi socovia vodka and of course
there's no laws when you're drinking
wakanda claws keep your actual summer
beverages cold with these soup can
koozies inspired by various marvel
costumes they've got captain american
spider can and the iron can mark 32. you
can't put a suit of armor around the
world but you sure can put one around
your gesh dang drink they've also
dropped their full multiverse of madness
collection with some spoilery items that
showcase the big cameos and moments from
the film epic hero is always putting out
cool creative merch inspired by your
favorite content you best believe that
they had an agatha all along or loki
variant shirt almost immediately after
those concepts entered our vocabulary
and hey if you have a background in
graphic design epic hero is looking for
designers to join them at their austin
office check the link in the description
prepare to have an epic summer at
epicuroshop.com with their summer themed
designs and their full multiverse of
madness collection to finally answer to
our question about strange's cloak we
need to look at one of the realms at the
center of the splinter realms limbo aka
the other place this limbo isn't the
traditional limbo we learned about
reading dante's inferno in high school
it's a pocket universe home to a wide
spectrum of demonic entities ruled by a
supreme sorcerer these demons can assume
any shape or form mandated by the
sorcerer if he or she is particularly
powerful however left to their own
devices these dark spirits will plot to
betray and conquer whoever holds the
highest power over them the title of
supreme sorcerer of the other place was
first held by belasco in the comics a
sorcerer who used his mastery of alchemy
in the black arts to strike a deal with
the elder gods allowing them to cross
over to our earthly dimensions in
exchange for immortality and ultimate
power he was eventually defeated and
sent to limbo but this dude made lemons
out of lemonade and spent his years
conquering the other place and ruling
the demons within so when the souls
began escaping strange's body as he
dream walked into his dead body i think
that the silent black in between space
he began to sink into was in fact his
soul being pulled into the other place
but like belasco strange was able to
command these souls forging them into a
soul cape pulled directly from the dark
dimension alternatively it's also
possible that strange red from the
portion of the darkhold called the
necronomicon during the scene the
necronomicon was derived from certain
parts of the darkhold and bound by an
alchemist named absul ahazred this is of
course a reference to h.p lovecraft's
fictional account of an arabian man by
the same name composing his version of
the necronomicon the necronomicon
surprisingly hasn't been name dropped
yet in the mcu in the comics however
this particular text allowed its reader
the ability to summon strange creatures
and stranger gods to their aid which
appears to be exactly what happens in
this scene of multiverse of madness
although the souls that eventually
formed strange's cape attacked him at
first the ability to summon and wrangle
these creatures could have come directly
from the pages of the necronomicon
within the darkhold because this is the
mcu and they're allowed to pick and
choose tiny details from different
comics to use as an outline for their
films and tv series i wouldn't be
surprised at all to learn that a
combination of these magic wielder's
stories velasco's and absol ahazred's
were used as inspiration for strange's
brief but impactful experience with the
soul cape and now that strange is
permanently stuck with an extra eyeball
on his forehead i think it's totally
possible that we might see more of his
ability to draw power from this realm in
between realms in the mcu although the
darkhold has been destroyed and doctor
strange is unlikely to dreamwalk into
his own rotting body again the ending of
multiverse of madness could be hinting
that he is now the supreme sorcerer in
command of these demons from limbo and
you gotta admit if our version of
strange can't be the sorcerer's supreme
of earth 616 this would be a pretty
metal alternative career trajectory
follow me on instagram and twitter at
whitney puppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you